on this wednesday night one of america's
worst school shootings
19 children and two teachers gunned down
in a texas classroom just an evil person
started shooting the backlash
why don't you get out of here the demand
lawmakers take action once and for all
neighbors helping neighbors did you have
any damage oh you want to see it yes i
would like to see it the community
effort to recover from a ferocious storm
bringing lost children home the delicate
and controversial work ahead at a bc
first nation
and teflon boris the british prime
minister tries to survive partygate
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight chris galas as a
nation
i think we all must be there for them
everyone
and we must ask when in god's name will
we do what needs to be done
to not completely stop fundamentally
change the amount of the carnage that
goes on in this country
to state the obvious
corey and a lot of other people here i'm
sick and tired
i'm just sick and tired
of what's going on
u.s president joe biden echoing what
many americans are feeling today after
yet another senseless massacre 19
children the victims of gun violence
some as young as 8 years old good
evening and thank you very much for
joining us everything about what
happened in texas on tuesday is deeply
disturbing and we're going to take you
through what we know tonight we'll begin
with jackson proskow who's in uvalde
texas now and jackson you've spoken to
families about how they are supporting
one another
good evening chris what makes this
tragedy so horrific is that it happened
in such a small town where everyone
knows someone who is in some way linked
to the tragedy inside that school and
all day long we've seen families coming
here to the site not only to bring fam
to bring flowers but to share memories
of the children and teachers who were
killed inside that building
[Music]
the grief in uvalde is impossible to
comprehend dozens of families forever
broken a small town now synonymous with
one of the worst gun massacres in modern
american history to the teachers that
worked at my campus their daughters were
murdered i was shot i was
disgusted i was angry i was
why no investigation will ever make
sense of what happened here an 18 year
old gunman stormed into an elementary
school and slaughtered little girls and
little boys in a grade four classroom at
rob elementary school
19 children
19 children
have lost their lives
two faculty members
lost their lives
uvalde's parents spent an agonizing
night at the local community center
giving dna samples to help identify the
bodies of their children
i got to find her after the shooting
they don't know where she's at
jessie rodriguez would later learn his
daughter 10 ten-year-old annabelle was
dead
nine-year-old amory joe garza is also
confirmed as a victim her father posted
this photo to facebook asking the
question why
teachers eva morelles and irma garcia a
mother of four died trying to save
students there's a hollowness that
happens there's a shock that happens and
i think right now that's pretty much
what everybody's feeling because it's
surreal
the murderous rampage came after the
gunman shot his own grandmother in the
face and fled from police crashing his
car before he entered the school
in the minutes before he started
shooting he made a facebook post
maybe less than 15 minutes before
arriving at the school was
i'm going to shoot in elementary school
but why he did it is the painful
question with no clear answer
just two days before the end of the
school year families are now planning
funerals instead of vacations as an
exasperated nation wonders how this
could happen again
no during a press conference the
governor of texas was shouted down by
beto o'rourke his democratic challenger
sir
a preview of how america's divide over
guns cannot be overcome by any amount of
senseless loss
jackson what are we learning about how
the violence ended up coming to an end
at that classroom yesterday
well chris we learned today that the
shooter was apparently inside the
schoolhouse for almost an hour he was
apparently shot and killed by a tactical
border patrol agent who was part of that
large police response here to the
building remember those police officers
came under fire several were injured
they had to be very very careful we also
know that more than a dozen students
were injured and have been hospitalized
some undergoing surgeries for
life-altering injuries after yesterday's
tragedy
jackson proskow in uvalde texas thank
you jackson
america's latest mass shooting has the
country once again wrestling with its
relationship with guns since january
first of this year there have been at
least 27 school shootings with injuries
or deaths across the united states in
that same time
213 mass shootings generally have taken
place in the u.s incidents where a
minimum of four victims were shot that's
an average of more than one and a half
mass shootings per day in 2022 now texas
governor greg abbott calls it a mental
health problem but he's made it much
easier to buy carry and use guns in his
state the official minimum age to own
and carry a gun is still 21 but when
house bill 1927 passed last fall texans
21 and older got clearance to carry
handguns in most places without a permit
or training nearly 60 percent of texans
were against that law
and while that law got the most
attention in 2021 abbott signed a total
of 22 pieces of state gun legislation
including a law that allows people as
young as 18 to buy a handgun if they
meet requirements to own one or can
prove they're under threat of violence
more than 150 thousand people are still
without power after last weekend's
deadly storm the grid was damaged from
southern ontario to quebec city and
while it will be weeks before the full
cost of the destruction is known
ottawa's cleanup will be covered by the
province david aiken visited some of the
hardest hit neighborhoods in the
nation's capital still dealing with the
aftermath i'm really concerned right now
about people who still do not have power
four days after the storm and city
councilor glenn gower has thousands of
his constituents still without power
phone service or the internet so he's
organized volunteers to canvas blacked
out neighborhoods what we're trying to
do today is get out there into the
community and go door to door and make
sure we're reaching people there are
dozens of streets like this one in
gower's ward in ottawa's west end
[Applause]
city work crews are just now 96 hours
later getting to the down power lines
and destroyed trees the amount of work
has been overwhelming did you have any
damage oh you want to see it yes i would
like to see it yeah
gower says the mood among those he
visits has been mostly good positive
appreciative but we're almost four days
into the no power situation so starting
to see a bit of a shift and
understandably people are starting to
get impatient and really wondering when
the the power is going to come back on
another big issue four days in food many
grocery stores have had to throw out
whole aisles of dairy products and
thawed frozen food that means some
neighborhoods have had limited access to
eggs milk butter meanwhile just cooking
what you have can pose some challenges
we're resourceful
we're campers so we've got some you know
we got a fair bit of equipment that we
can use for outdoor cooking but at the
end of the day it is all about getting
power back no matter how you do it we
were very fortunate to find a generator
yesterday and now the challenge is
getting the gasoline and keeping that
going for sure but generators are very
hard to come by in the city right now
the pandemic of course was the kind of
crisis that isolated people it
disconnected neighborhoods but this
crisis this destruction is having the
opposite effect it is reconnecting
neighborhoods and bringing people
together chris
good to see it that's david aiken in
ottawa thanks david
victoria international airport is back
to normal now after suspicious items in
a passenger's checked luggage led to a
six-hour shutdown last night rcmp say
security flagged the man's luggage
during a scan and they shut the airport
down while experts determined if the
items were actually explosive today
police say the items were quote inert
military surplus explosives the
passenger was arrested and then released
with an upcoming court date nearly two
dozen flights were affected by the
closure
toronto public health is investigating
two suspected and two probable cases of
monkey pox there are already 16
confirmed cases of the rare infectious
disease in canada all of them in quebec
health officials say the risk of
transmission in social settings is low
but as dan spector explains the number
of confirmed cases is expected to rise
in the coming days
we have many kids who are busy at this
clinic in montreal doctors say they're
dealing with a monkey pox panic three
confirmed cases have come through here
and dr regina thomas says as test
results come back more will be confirmed
this morning we saw one one man who have
a blister in the face
and near the eye
montreal is the epicenter of a growing
canadian outbreak the number of
confirmed cases in the city tripling
since friday so far the spread is
happening mostly among men who've had
close prolonged contact it can start
with flu-like symptoms then lead to
lesions appearing on the body and
lasting up to three weeks we know the
virus spreads through direct contact
prolonged contact most of the time is
sexual contract
at this clinic a few blocks away dr
robert pilarski has treated several
scared patients presenting symptoms big
centers like toronto and vancouver
they're going to spread pretty fast too
there are now two probable and two
suspected cases in toronto according to
ontario public health one of the men had
been in montreal first it's been cooking
under the radar for for a little while
and that's why we're suddenly seeing so
many cases
the world health organization says there
are at least 250 confirmed and suspected
cases of monkey pox in more than 16
countries data is still being gathered
but scientists say in most cases it's
not deadly and is not transmitted by
casual skin-to-skin contact like
brushing up against someone in public
transit it's not like covet where lots
of people get very sick and fair number
of people die federal officials say
vaccines have been sent to quebec
pilarski is hoping to start immunizing
people as soon as possible i don't know
why it's taking so long there are
currently no mandatory isolation
requirements in canada we should follow
the belgium we should probably store the
mandatory quarantine for 21 days
meanwhile dr thomas seeks government
help to boost staffing on the front
lines as his small team rolls up its
sleeves to battle a mysterious foe dan
specter global news montreal
britain's prime minister answers for
party gate coming up what a new report
says about boris johnson's rule-breaking
shindigs plus a whale of a tale the
risky rescue off the spanish coast
spanish divers carry out a daring rescue
operation to free a humpback whale it
had become trapped in an illegal
driftnet near majorca the divers plunged
into action and spent 45 minutes cutting
the mesh off which was so entangled the
whale could not even open its mouth
the united nations banned driftnets 30
years ago after earning the nickname
walls of death for the creatures they
catch in addition to the fish that they
are set for
turns out teflon boris is keeping his
nickname a new independent report about
the downing street events attended by
british prime minister boris johnson
during covet 19 lockdowns revealed boozy
parties some of which should never have
happened at all but as europe bureau
chief crystal gumansing reports
criticism never seems to stick and
johnson remains in number 10 tonight
i take full responsibility for
everything that took place on my watch a
critical new independent report makes
clear the british prime minister's watch
included boozy parties in or near 10
downing street
boris johnson reportedly attended nine
of 16 gatherings under scrutiny
one party in june 2020 resulted in the
pm being fined because it broke his own
coveted lockdown rules yeah it's left a
very bitter taste that might never go
i just don't think we're in good hands
currently that report lays bare the rot
that under this prime minister has
spread in number 10.
while his political rivals and some from
the voting public had harsh words for
the prime minister his own conservative
mps who said they were waiting for the
report to pass judgment appear to be
giving johnson a pass it is now time to
turn a page
there is still one more review into
what's known as partygate across the uk
it seeks to determine if johnson
deliberately misled parliament over the
pandemic parties
because it's already clear that those
who made the rules here had little
problem breaking them
crystal gamansen global news london
just ahead one year later new details
about the plan to bring residential
schools lost children home
you're watching global national
this week marks one year since the
tecumelips to schwettman first nation
revealed 215 suspected unmarked graves
mostly of children had been found on the
grounds of a former residential school
after months of grieving the indigenous
community is moving forward now with the
plan to identify the remains and bring
the missing children home our anitu
garcia has an inside look at the
unprecedented process
walking into the former kamloops indian
residential school where he helps
revitalize the to come loops to
schweitman traditional language ted
goffertson carries a new weight of the
legacy left by the very institution that
made his job necessary it was
a quick decision even though it wasn't a
light one
to have the kids return back to their
communities more than 200 unmarked
burials found here are set to be exhumed
for identification and potentially
reunited with the communities they were
taken from it's sacred ground and it's
of the utmost importance to leave them
where they are
but
as we can all
admit and know
this isn't your typical situation
monday's memorial marked one year since
the remains were detected at a nearby
old apple orchard on the site of the
former school grounds
ultimately
we have a fundamental human right
to bury our loved ones at home
some are firmly against that plan and
gotfordson whose mother was sent to the
institution serves on a committee to
determine the best way forward we all
understand
what it means to move the kids to
disturb them
there's no one who doesn't
understand that the process includes
oral tellings from elders who survived
guiding more ground penetrating radar
work and sharing memories of loved ones
who went missing
these are steps we have to take before
we even
get the arc the forensic archaeologists
in there to begin their work because
once they start
we're we're heading for a world of hurt
for our people in terms of a timeline of
where are things at now and how long
could it take
years
it's going to take years
and a lot of money which he says the
federal government should provide the
prime minister only making a broad
promise during his visit here this week
whatever communities decide is the right
path for them the federal government
will be there to support
so many extremely sensitive and
difficult decisions are being made here
and it's an uncharted path so goffertson
says they're taking their time while
prioritizing science and cultural
protocols chris
nitu garcia in kamloops bc tonight thank
you neethu and a reminder there is
support available for survivors of
residential schools and their families
the number is toll free it operates 24
hours a day it's 1-800-721-0066
up next firing back 10 years after
america's deadliest school shooting hope
this is the turning point
i just worry that we are becoming numb
to this that we are accepting this as
the new normal this is the only place in
the world that this happens there's not
a single country in the world in which
kids fear for their lives when they walk
into school in the morning
that's us senator chris murphy echoing
what many people americans and otherwise
feel in the wake of the senseless
massacre in texas many people point an
accusing finger at the gun lobby after
tragedies like this continue to happen
this weekend the national rifle
association gathers in texas but the
organization has a long history of
deflecting criticism of gun violence
away from gun ownership and
accessibility eric sorenson looks at the
uphill battle to change gun laws in
america
uvalde texas is like all mass shootings
from virginia tech to parkland florida
they are tragic and senseless but it is
most like sandy hook in newtown
connecticut young children slaughtered
at school without a clue what was
happening or why but there is a
disheartening difference after sandy
hook there was a glimmer of hope for
change to gun laws in the u.s i really
really believe this will be the start of
something in 1994 a temporary ban on
assault weapons brought fewer mass
killings in the united states the ban
expired but a spate of shootings
culminating in sandy hook brought new
resolve that something would be done
about guns i'll protect our second
amendment rights conservative democrat
joe manchin said even he was ready to
act i ask all my friends in nra we need
to sit down and move this dialogue to a
sensible reasonable approach but the
national rifle association had its own
solutions to put armed police in every
school the only thing
that stops a bad guy with a gun
is a good guy with a gun and since then
guns and mass shootings have
proliferated and today senator manchin
calls for background checks but not
restricting gun ownership and we have to
reach across the bench but we can't
politicize it has to be done in such a
practical way it just makes sense
nowadays republican senators have a
tried and true response to guns the most
effective tool for keeping kids safe
is armed law enforcement on the campus
we know what is effective and it is
targeting the felons and fugitives and
the bad guys
but never targeting the guns now in the
u.s there are more guns than people and
for those who want change there is only
boiling frustration nowhere else do
little kids go to school thinking that
they might be shot that day nowhere else
does that happen except here in the
united states of america and it is a
choice a choice like the choice today by
texas lawmakers to focus on mental
health not the gunman's assault weapons
so when texas democrat beto o'rourke
stepped forward to call them out he was
shouted down i can't believe you're a
sick son that would come to a deal like
this to make a political issue here when
are we going to do something basketball
coach steve kerr like many americans
knows that life and basketball will just
go on i'm sorry i'm tired of the moments
of silence
enough
right now in the u.s there is anger and
pressure to do more but history suggests
the pressure usually passes and the
anger will fade
erik sorensen global news toronto
and that's global national for this
wednesday i'm chris galas we'll leave
you tonight with images that say more
than words ever could about the grief in
uvalde 21 lives taken 19 of them young
children and yet another brutal mass
shooting in the u.s now all too familiar
for that country with no resolution in
sight
thanks for watching
[Music]
you